so uh radical repugnant republican
congresswoman lauren bobert or bo bear
depending on your preference spoke at
the turning point event over the weekend
in tampa florida
she apropos of seemingly nothing
although there actually is a backstory
but nobody knew it she denied being a
prostitute for ted cruz now it's not
clear whether she means that ted cruz
was her pimp and that's what she's
denying or that ted cruz was the john
and that's what she's denied i don't
know which she's denying but she is
denying it check this out this is a
congresswoman folks
about ted cruz lately in the news
and contrary to populative belief
i have never been an escort
for senator ted cruz
but i will tell you tonight it is the
coolest thing i've ever heard about ted
cruz
she was not a prostitute for ted cruz
and whether that means with ted cruz as
the client or ted cruz as the pimp
but regardless uh it would be cool if
ted cruz was doing that i guess it's all
very strange now this actually does
relate to something this story did not
get a lot of attention it was the story
was pitched to me and i didn't cover it
because the sourcing on it was sketchy
and just didn't make sense to cover it
there was a group that made claims about
lauren beaubert including that she was
an escort or prostitute and it was not
um you know when when i looked at it it
didn't look like lauren bober in the
picture and indeed cnn said the woman in
the picture is not beau bear and there
were all sorts of other incorrect claims
made but it was not really a widely
known story
so
heard bringing up and saying listen let
me just tell you i was not an escort
okay just kind of a weird moment one
other
uh kind of interesting moment
is uh when lauren beaubert put together
a very strange word salad that was
completely unintelligible see if you can
make heads or tails out of this
position yourself for this newness this
newness that we are coming into
we are going to take our country back
together we are not drawing back we are
pressing in every single day that's why
you're here
getting equipped for this right if you
can understand that
please email me and explain to me what
she's saying about positioning yourself
for the new ness the newness the newness
crazy conference and the crowd will
cheer for anything uh after the break
we'll look at one more clip from this
event from matt gates and then move on
to other things stay with us we'll be
right back